-The "Community" cast
had a virtual reunion.
-Yes.
-How did it go? Was it fun?
Did you enjoy doing that?
-Oh, it was -- I can't --
I mean, now I'm being sincere,
but it was -- it was like
going to a family reunion
with family that
you actually liked.
-Aww.
-And it was -- I cried after.
Like, we all were
texting afterwards,
and we were all so happy.
Yeah, we raised a bunch of money
for Frontline Foods
for essential workers and for
the World Central Kitchen.
And, you know, like -- you know,
Donald Glover was there,
and he's -- as you know,
his career has tanked.
So this is --
He really needed this.
-He needed the virtual
"Community" reunion.
-You know,
the "Star Wars" movies
and the Emmys and the Grammys.
-Yeah, sure. Of course.
-Like, none of those have really
helped his career, so this --
-You've all done pretty well.
What is the -- There's a rumor
that a possibility of
a "Community" movie.
-Yes, and we are coming to you
to ask
for some financing because
we know you have that -- I think
NBC calls it "F-You" money,
which I think is an insult.
No, there is a g--
there's a good chance, I think,
because on the Zoom,
everyone got asked,
and Donald said he would do it.
And he's the busiest man
in show business, so --
and then Dan -- we'll see
because Dan's got to write it,
and he's got like
100 "Rick and Morty" episodes
that he has to make.
-Yeah.
-But I think we would all do it
if we are --
you know, if we're --
If Dan writes it,
it sounds like people will make
themselves available.
-That would be a lot of fun.
You're hosting the second season
of "Card Sharks."
You were here
for the first season,
and it went on to be
the biggest summer show of ABC
in like 10 years or something
crazy like that.
Congratulations on that.
You're one of the first shows
to go back
into production
during the pandemic.
What was that like?
-Yeah.
Well, it's nice of you
to say the show was popular.
No, it -- we --
Us and "The Mandalorian"
were the first shows
back in production,
and as you know,
both shows are equally popular
and same audience
and production value.
But see, the thing is
we're better than "Mandalorian"
because we gave away money,
and what did they give us?
Just a wonderful, adorable,
you know, baby Yoda.
That's -- That's not cash money.
So, yeah -- no, I -- I --
Thankfully it worked,
and they had all these zones
that people moved in.
There was -- At one point, they
thought somebody was positive,
but it was just
an inconclusive test,
but those people
were quarantined.
We were able to continue.
-Yeah, you got to
take it seriously. Yeah.
-Yeah. So actually --
it actually worked.
And as you know, there's so many
people not working right now,
so to have a way to proceed
and have people get to be able
to make money for their families
has been --
you know, it's great.
So I -- You know, what I'm
saying is I'm responsible for...
-[ Laughs ] Just stop.
-...the recovery of
the economy, so you're welcome.
You're welcome. Cheers.
-[ Laughs ]
That's not what
you're saying at all.
-I don't know
how to end sentences!
It just kind of ramps up,
and I just keep going,
and I can't stop.
I don't know.
-[ Laughs ]
You're a funny guy.
You're a loving guy.
You give back whenever you can,
and I appreciate that.
You know I'm a big fan.
Congrats on the new season.
Have a great fall season.
Stay safe, please.
-Thank you.
-And save a bottle of wine
for when we can hang out
with each other, okay?
-I've got -- And just send me
your -- Just tell me
your address of your house
that you invited me to
during the break.
That would be great.
Just go ahead.
-The new season of "Card Sharks"
premieres October 18th on ABC.
We're talking to Big Sean
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.
-I'm dropping an album too.
It's called "Detroit 2," so...
-Like, "also," T-O-O?
-Oh, no, I can't believe it.
It's the same name. Shoot.
Well, tell Sean I had it first,
and he has to change it.